love is a really special thing and
I think
meeting someone that you really connect
with is really really special so and you
are such an amazing human being I'm
sorry but you are like the world's great
catch like oh you are you are Chris I
know you
I know who you are inside we all know
your work on the out the outside but you
are you are such a good person I can't
think of anyone who deserves happiness
more Here's To Love
you can encourage me by the way is there
a photo of you guys is this is this yeah
oh hello oh my God look at you guys okay
and his name is Lucas Gage
is that it yeah that is that's Lucas
um it's in Mexico looking looking like
an ad for something that I just want to
be a part of